a head nurse at UCLA sits me down and
she says Point Blank UCLA doesn't
support women who are pregnant or help
them so it was very crystal clear
immediately why there's no pregnant
girls on campus because we were being
told point blank you should have an
abortion
[Music]
hey hey and welcome to the Ben Shapiro
show Sunday special this week I'm
excited to welcome Lila Rose Lila is
founder and president of live-action one
of the leading pro-life and human rights
organizations in the country she's also
the host of the while arrow show we'll
get to our questions for Lila Rose in
just one moment first you know the
reality is that the markets are pretty
volatile and one of the factors in
volatility is the fact that central
governments can actually manipulate
currencies this is one of the reasons
why some people are looking into
investing into cryptocurrency I know
crypto what what the hell is it
basically it's like an online gold it's
an asset that cannot be manipulated by
outside currency manipulators like China
last week for example China devalued its
currency and markets tanked one
consequence was that the price of
Bitcoin rose why because Bitcoin can't
be manipulated that way it might be time
to seriously consider including some
crypto in your portfolio the best place
to trade crypto is eToro eToro is smart
crypto trading made easy eToro social
trading platform has over 11 million
traders and facilitates over 1 trillion
dollars in trading volume per year
globally you can access the world's best
crypto currencies they got 15 different
coins available
you got low and transparent fees you can
try before you trade with a virtual
portfolio with a 100,000 dollar budgets
you can actually see how the thing works
before you spend your own money on it
never miss a trading trend with charts
and pricing alerts as well then I think
that crypto is definitely worth taking a
look at and that's why I'm encouraging
you to take a look at it at eToro comm
slash Schapiro that's Ichi Oro comm
slash Schapiro eToro comm slash Schapiro
viola thanks so much for joining us
thanks for having me Ben so why don't we
start off by explaining what live action
is for folks who are not familiar with
the group sure so live action is the
digital leader right now for the
pro-life movement we reach millions of
people every day with pro-life content
to educate hearts and minds both about
what abortion is the violence it does to
a baby and then the beauty of life
motherhood fatherhood how good and
important it is to fight for life and we
do a lot of investigative reporting of
the Planned Parenthood the abortion
industry and we reach especially young
people so lots of teens 20s 30s so in a
second don't ask about some of the
specifics that you've done with live
action but first how did you get into
this issue in the first place because
you and I first met one you were maybe
17 and you were working at UCLA and
you're and you're working on exposing
the abortion industry but what made you
it
to get into exposing the abortion
industry the first place sure so it
wasn't like just a hobby that I got into
is it felt like a calling when I was a
teenager because I learned about
abortion as a young girl I'm from the
Bay Area California one of eight kids
and oldest of five of them so the third
oldest and just growing up in that kind
of a household life was very precious
you know it's a gift and then when I
found out about abortion my parents
weren't activists but they were more
conservative politically and I found out
found out about abortion by reading this
book that they had in their living room
called a handbook on abortion by dr. and
mrs. Wilke just old kind of 1980s
looking book and they didn't like give
it to me I just found it cuz I was
reading every book in the house at the
time was very into books and I just came
across facts about what abortion what
was happening with abortion in America
and I saw photos of a child in the first
trimester so it's amazing how quickly
this a baby grows I mean I'm third
trimester right now but first trimester
tiny but still by ten weeks you have
newly formed arms legs of tiny newly
formed little face the heart's beating
after three weeks brain waves after six
weeks but I saw this image of a child in
the first trimester who'd been killed by
abortion and I remember looking at this
as a young girl and thinking what is
this is this real is this happening I
started to do research I started to ask
questions and I find out that there's
3,000 abortions every day in our country
I start to read up on it I come across
mother Teresa writing and speaking about
it whose becomes a hero to me and she
calls abortion the greatest destroyer of
peace because she says in a nation where
a mother can kill her own child
what is left but for you or for I to
kill one another and just absorbing all
this fun I was I was deeply moved and I
thought this is the human rights issue
of our day not a lot of people are
talking about it
not a lot of people are doing stuff
about it but this is a human rights
issue and I have to do something about
it so as a teenager my resolution was
I'm going to try to save some lives by
educating other people because by
education I became aware of the problem
and so that led me to when I got to UCLA
doing investigative reporting because I
thought again I have to educate my
fellow students here there there's so
much misinformation about abortion he's
not even talked about and when it is
about lies are told about the humanity
of the child the risks of abortion so
the rest was history from there so when
we talk about some of your early
research over at UCLA the kind of
undercover stuff that you are doing
because you really did pioneer this
space I mean you were doing some of this
stuff at the same time the James O'Keefe
was doing stuff uncovering acorn this is
sort of the early days of undercover
conservative citizen journalism so what
what exactly was it that you were doing
sure so when I got to UCLA I started a
newspaper magazine on campus which was
meant to compete with the daily Bruin
which I wrote a couple of heads for I
don't know if you ever wrote for that I
did they throw away a few I would I kept
submitting pro-life articles and they
only had so much appetite for so many
and maybe they published too but the
point was it was very pro-abortion the
faculty the administration as you may
remember it's all very proportion I mean
you can't find a pro-life professor on
campus they're going to be pushing their
politics in the classroom and a lot of
the students I thought were actually
more open-minded they just weren't
getting any other information and this
was right when social media was just
starting so YouTube had just launched
Facebook we just had our new UCLA
Facebook accounts and so there was
finally a way to get other information
out that's not the typical traditional
media or the typical you know what
you're learning in the classroom and so
starting this magazine I realized I'm
going to do independent reporting
because no one's talking about what's
happening - pregnant students at UCLA
because girls were getting pregnant at
our health center there were over a
thousand pregnancy tests that were done
in one year in the last reported year
but I never saw a pregnant girl on
campus why what's happening to them and
then what's happening with the abortion
clinics in Los Angeles so that opened my
my mind in my curiosity to say okay what
can I discover what can I expose maybe
just doing my own investigative work and
so my first investigation was actually
of our campus health center Arthur Ashe
health and wellness center right in the
middle of Bruin walk and I just went in
posing as Lila saying I was you know 18
a freshman which I was but saying I
think I might be pregnant and the head
nurse at UCLA sits me down and this is a
woman that she saw all the students who
might be pregnant who were taking
pregnancy tests and she looks me in the
eyes and she says Point Blank UCLA
doesn't support women who are pregnant
or help them
she said but we have two doctors you can
see you can pick which one for two
different kinds of abortion procedures
and when I asked her about other options
I said well what about you know are
there other options for me besides
abortion she said that adoption would be
like giving away present she said that
being pregnant in class would be
embarrassing for me and my fellow
classmates cuz I'd have to use the
bathroom and it was just not worth it
and so I should go the route and get a
UCLA doctor to do an abortion on me so
it was very crystal clear immediately
why there's no pregnant girls on campus
because despite UCLA being all about
your choices and empowerment and women
can accomplish anything we were being
told point blank you should have an
abortion I mean that is obviously very
stunning stuff and then you proceeded to
go undercover at Planned Parenthood
exactly so why you talk about that yeah
so after the Health Center and reporting
on that in my magazine that we launched
called advocate on campus we also
realized okay it's time to look at the
abortion clinic clinics in Los Angeles
because this is where girls are often
being sent this is where they're going
students are going and I had done a lot
of research and discovered in the
practice of abortion there's a lot of
other human rights abuses so it's
abortion is this ultimate abuse against
a child it's killing a human being in
the womb but it is harmful to the mother
it's harmful to the father it's harmful
to the whole all of our familial bonds
for society and when abortion clinics
are committing these horrific acts
against children they're often not
really concerned about the woman either
she's becomes a second victim and I had
done research showing how it's seen
research showing how sex abuse victims
are often taken or traffic victims are
taken to abortion clinics where the
crime that they endured the assault the
abuse if they're an underage girl often
it can result in a pregnancy and then
they're taken to this abortion clinic
it's covered up by the clinic instead of
the abortion facility reporting it to
two authorities that they're the way
they're required to do by law and so I
came across a study by Marc Cutler this
group called life dynamics out of Texas
as a kind of older guard pro-life group
but they called over 800 Planned
Parenthood facilities and found that in
over 90% of them they and they had a
girl posing as an underage girl on the
phone 13 years old and over 90 percent
of 800
Planned Parenthood clinics at the time
they told who they thought was a 13 year
old girl that they had a Don't Ask Don't
Tell policy on sex abuse meaning she
could come in if she was pregnant the
abuser could even take her in the boy
the older boyfriend and they wouldn't do
anything about the abuse and they
wouldn't report it which they're
required by law to do in virtually every
state so reading this reading the
stories of actual girls who had been
through this and then they later on sued
Planned Parenthood or there were
criminal cases I was very moved by that
I thought wow women children are being
killed and women are being harmed so is
that happening in LA and so that led me
to go undercover posing as an underage
girl saying that I was the victim of
abuse had a much older boyfriend
statutory rape and instead of reporting
it in the first to Los Angeles Planned
Parenthood clinics I went into both of
them told me that I could lie about my
age in the paperwork they wouldn't
report it and they offered to give me a
secret abortion that immediately
two-for-two I realized this is not just
Los Angeles this is not just bad stuff
at UCLA this is stuff happening all over
the country that no one is talking about
and so that inspired that first
investigative reporting and then taking
it across the country I mean it is
pretty astounding how you have uncovered
all of this stuff and sort of like the
David daleiden case there have been so
many cases where Planned Parenthood has
been exposed and the media have a vested
interest in ensuring that people do not
hear about the abuses that take place at
places like Planned Parenthood how do
you think the media are able to get away
with with what really doesn't mount to a
fairly large-scale cover-up well I mean
it's no surprise that the trust in the
media is an all-time low people don't
think the media is trustworthy anymore
because they're not reporting stories
that matter or they're actually covering
for abusers or for people that or
companies or organizations that align
with their political ideology like
Planned Parenthood like an abortion
industry but are actually doing horrific
things on the daily and breaking the law
I mean not just killing children and
killing thousands of children a day but
lying to women manipulating breaking
state laws covering up sexual abuse I
mean so many horrific abuses alongside
that abuse of abortion so you know and
it's not just media I mean as we know
it's tech big tech I mean Sheryl
Sandberg
CEO of Facebook just donated her second
million dollars to Planned Parenthood
and you have live action has over
four million followers online on social
media but we are dealing daily with all
kinds of tech bias so media bias is bad
but I think people at this party like
okay other media is biased you know CNN
and MSNBC whatever they're biased but
it's even more devious when you have
Google making the search results with
you type in abortion risks there all
these Planned Parenthood articles saying
there's no risks to abortion right or
you're on you're looking at you're just
your social media feed on Facebook or
your social media feed on Twitter and
you're not seeing necessarily the facts
about what abortion actually is coming
from alternate voices instead you're
seeing stuff that corroborates or
fulfills that idea of pro-abortion
ideology which a lot of the folks at in
San Francisco in big tech support so
it's a big problem and it's something
that I mean that's my daily wires so
great fight back you know spread of
different spread to different narrative
because it's that other pro-abortion
narrative is so strong right now well
where do you think that we stand on
abortion in the country right now
because there are some conflicting polls
shows some show that Americans are
largely in favor of some restrictions on
abortion others when taken just in terms
of re probe Roe vs. Wade or anti Roe
versus Wade show majority in favor of
Roe vs. Wade where do you think the
American people are on this issue
well I'm very encouraged so there have
been some of the latest Gallup polls
show that more people identify as
pro-life than pro-choice
so that's a label and that can mean a
lot of different things to different
people so that's one one indicator I
think the thing that's the most
interesting is when you look at people's
position on the legality of abortion and
the reality is according to most of the
recent polls whether it's pew or Gallup
or others the vast majority of Americans
want significant abortion restrictions
so they want abortion restricted to the
first trimester or banned altogether and
I think that's really telling I think
most people realize that this is a moral
issue they're not comfortable with it
they don't support it and they don't
like that we have it but they think oh
we need to compromise right because they
don't want to be seen as extreme because
the moment you come out and say I'm
pro-life for all children no matter what
then the media says you're crazy you're
an extremist you're a zealot and so most
people are like okay well I at least
want some restrictions but what we see
every day at live action is when we
actually educate people when they
actually know facts about fetal
development
about life in the womb the heart beating
at just a little over three weeks it
means crazy brain waves at just a little
over six weeks when they learn about how
quickly that child grows when they learn
about the science which proves
conclusively this is an unique
individual human life at the moment of
fertilization people become pro-life a
lot more people than you would realize
and when they see what abortion does to
that baby when you actually learn what
these abortion procedures do to starve
that baby to death whether it's it
through a pill in the first trimester or
to tear that suction that baby apart in
the second trimester or the late first
people are shocked and they say wow I
can't support that so we're seeing now
those minds change on the daily when we
do our work at live action it's not
being reported you know it's like you're
not gonna see a feature story on CNN
about this girl who changed her mind on
abortion but little by little I think
that the tide is absolutely turning so
in a second I want to ask you about the
the scientific questions surrounding
abortion but first have you ever
wondered why internet access is so much
cheaper these days like 30 or 40 bucks a
month used to cost you hundreds of bucks
a month well that would be because
internet service providers like Comcast
and AT&T are not just making money off
subscription fees they're also making
money from spying on your internet
activity and then selling your history
and data to big tech companies which is
why I use expressive VPN to make sure
they don't get hold of my data it's my
data encryption makes it much harder to
spy on you which is why companies like
Time Warner and Verizon don't actually
want you using expressvpn the best way
to make sure the 100% of your data is
encrypted from your ISP
is with expressvpn expressvpn creates a
secure tunnel between all your devices
and the internet so everything you do
online is encrypted not even your isp
can track and collect data on you
expressvpn works on all your devices not
just your phone or your computer works
on tablets and smart TVs even your
router so you and your whole family can
always stay protected I can't stress
this enough expressvpn is incredibly
simple to use you just open up the app
you tap one button to connect and that
is it that's the reason I use Express
VPN there are hackers big tech lots
folks who want my data they don't get it
it's my data your data is your business
to protect it and express it VPN comm /
Ben visit expressvpn saath kaam / ben to
get three extra months of expressvpn
protection for free
that's expressvpn comm / Ben to learn
more ok so let's talk about the the
science surrounding abortion
one of the things that drives me
absolutely upper walls we've now been
through probably 15 or 20 minutes at
this interview you've not mentioned your
religious stance once and yet when you
talk with people who are pro-choice or
when you read the columns written by
people who are pro-choice their
fundamental assumption their baseline
assumption seems to be that if you're
pro-life the reason that you're pro-life
is because you're religious so this
really is two questions one why is that
assumption made and two why is it there
is such heavy crossover between people
who are pro-life and people who are
religious when the science again should
tend toward making people pro-life why
aren't there more secondly pro-lifers in
other words right I think it's because
of actual literal science denial that's
happening on the Left largely even among
those who say that they are we're pro
science you know look at climate change
look at all these things they won't
actually look and acknowledge
acknowledge the biological realities of
what's happening with life in the womb I
mean we deal with this all the time
we're educating young people I was just
talking with a young girl just in the
last few days he was saying I'm an
atheist
so I'm pro-choice and I said well let's
talk about that when does life begin and
she said well I think it's just an egg
early on in the first trimester I said
well that's actually scientifically
incorrect an egg a sperm fertilizes an
egg then you have a single cell embryo
and that's a unique individual human
life that's what the science shows and
it was like mind blowing for this young
girl and I said where are you getting
your information and she said oh I'm
just getting it from you know a friend
that is more liberal or something like
that and I said if you actually pick up
any human biology textbook any human
biology textbook it will tell you when
life begins it begins at the moment of
fertilization when that egg completely
is transformed because of the sperm and
becomes a complete DNA code for an
individual human life and all that life
needs is time and nourishment to grow so
I think it's really just this crazy
environment that we're in today where
this basic science about the origin of
human life is being hidden from people
or because of our our obsession with
making keeping abortion legal and
defending it to the death we are
refusing to acknowledge basic scientific
realities about human life and to your
second question about people who are
religious who tend to be a lot more
pro-life I mean I think that's because
when you start to have any kind of a
moral view of the universe and everybody
everybody is religious in some way even
an atheist
their religion is I believe there's no
God absolutely right or agnostic their
religion is I don't know and so I'm
going to live my life the certain way
everybody has a worldview we'll call it
religion call it worldview it's the way
they live their lives is the code by
which they live and what is the code by
which we will live in our society if
people of most major faiths today are
pro-life because they acknowledge human
life has to be precious human life has
to be valuable if we don't see the value
of every single human life then all of a
sudden we enter into all kinds of in
justices and and justifications for for
abuses against human dignity and that's
where human rights abuses how they
happen because we start to dehumanize
one group of the population be it
whether because of their sex or because
of their race or because of their
political background or their faith or
their size their level of development
because they're so small they're there
in the womb so I think it makes sense
with your religious to be pro-life if
you're not religious or your worldview
is whatever you want it to be if you
think that human beings have human
rights you should be pro-life period one
of the things they you mention when you
talk about science denial and that is
completely obvious is how the Left
wishes to deny the ability of people to
even see ultrasound photos it's
absolutely astonishing I mean I've met
my listeners know my wife is is now six
months a little bit over six months
pregnant and she's due at the beginning
of March you're obviously pregnant the
quality of the ultrasound now is so
unbelievably high when we had the first
of all for sound of the newest kid and I
think eight or nine weeks the quality of
the ultrasound is so unbearable for
sound it looks like a full child I mean
it looks like a child and while that's
not a great argument for what
constitutes a human life because the
look of something doesn't necessarily
mean what it is it is so perfectly
obvious on its face what exactly you are
looking at that it's no wonder that
groups like Planned Parenthood wish to
forcibly discourage people from taking a
look at ultrasounds and it even it's
even like when you look at miscarriage I
mean planned parent is now ex-president
dr. Leana when she wrote publicly about
a miscarriage that she had and this was
right before she was fired by Planned
Parenthood so this happened over the
summer was this big hullabaloo and she's
the first doctor in dozens of years at
Planned Parenthood allowed to be their
head and then she wasn't pro-abortion
enough for them but she wrote this
article sick talking about
the grief she felt after her miscarriage
that same baby that same age couldn't be
killed legally at Planned Parenthood
clinics across the country and why is
the child you know you have a baby
shower you're pregnant with a baby
you're expecting a baby why all of a
sudden it's completely illogical is it
no longer a baby no longer life no
longer someone to be grieved just
because you don't confer value on it as
the parent or the the person making the
decision it's not logical and I think
the more people learn about facts about
life in the womb what abortion is they
realize it's not logical and so to be
logical to be pro science to be
reasonable this is a life that deserves
protection like you or or like I do so
why do you think it is that the left has
moved away from what seemed to be a lot
safer political ground even 25 years ago
the safe legal and rare formulation the
idea that sure this is uncomfortable
sure we're not saying that it's totally
morally fine but at the same time there
are certain people who are in need and
we wouldn't want to make it illegal we
want to make it safe for them to get an
abortion why do you think the left has
forcibly disabused themselves of this
notion I mean now you're seeing the
full-on
celebrate abortion shout your abortion
light up towers in New York pink if
you're gonna legalize abortion up some
points of birth why do you think the
left has made that radical shift because
it is a a politically bewildering shift
one of those formulations is a lot more
popular than the other yeah no I think
you're right and all the Democratic
candidates right now unfortunately are
all pro-abortion I mean pretty much
they're all nine months tulsi gabbard
it's like maybe in the third trimester
there's some babies that we should
protect who they yell at her exactly I
think there's two things first of all
the abortion lobbies extremely powerful
Planned Parenthood has been receiving
over half of a billion dollars in
taxpayer money for years and years and
years so they've been receiving multi
billions from the federal government and
from state governments and their
political power is huge they've invested
30 million to try to defeat Trump last
round they're going to invest another 50
million this coming round so the
abortion Lobby is a real thing and they
have a lot of power with these
politicians and they are only content
with abortion through all nine months or
any reason they they have no there's no
moderation when it comes to the abortion
industry I mean of course not they want
to kill and they want licensed to kill
at any age for any reason so there's
that I think the second thing though is
they're they're actually being logically
consistent now Ben
I mean before they weren't right and I
think they're kind of realizing wow if
we compromise it's not too long until we
might find herself out of a job as being
pro-abortion or you know supporting the
abortion industry because once you say
you can protect some lives then the
argument - why don't we just protect
them all if they're human lives to begin
with is a very strong one so I think now
they're actually being logically
consistent by saying nope if they're in
the womb doesn't matter how old doesn't
matter for what reason you should have
license to kill so over a live action
obviously do an enormous amount of
outreach that's what you do and I want
to ask you in just a second about what
are the most effective types of outreach
in order the least effective types of
outreach on this particular issue but
first let's talk about a great new movie
it's called no safe spaces okay it's
made by my friends Adam Carolla and
Dennis Prager Adam of course is the
godfather of the podcasting industry and
Dennis Prager who is sort of a a moral
voice and the conservative universe has
been for four decades they made a great
new phone it's called no safe space it's
in theaters nationwide Friday December
6th Adam and Dennis taken a wild ride to
show you the effects of political
correctness identity politics and cancel
culture no safe spaces argues that free
speech is important in a free society
it shows how it's being threatened and
what we can do to fight back it also
features me in this film so if you like
me if you're a fan of ben shapiro you
should check out no safe spaces because
they review my experiences at Cal State
Los Angeles and that weird one over at
Berkeley where the city had to spend
like six hundred thousand dollars on
security just I could talk about free
speech the film also features Van Jones
jordan peterson brett weinstein Cornel
West even President Obama this is a film
that you can take and you should take
your liberal friends to see no safe
spaces rated pg-13 is now playing in
theaters everywhere that's no safe
spaces calm / Ben for ticket information
and theater locations so let's talk for
a second about the effective approaches
on the pro-life side versus the
ineffective approaches on the pro-life
side so you spent an awful lot of time
an awful lot of money trying to reach
out to people with pro-life messages so
you probably have some good information
about what is effective and what is
ineffective when we start the
ineffective what's been the least
effective approach that you think people
use when it comes to moving people
toward a pro-life position that's a good
question I mean first of all there's a
lot of diversity so I would say there
are some really not silver bullets but
there are some really strong arguments
and approaches that work for a lot of
people but some people it's interesting
that
even some of the lesser effective
approaches in the pro-life movement
still make a difference for some people
so I would never say stop doing what
you're doing out there anybody doing
anything for life lovingly with
compassion I think is good whether it's
very effective in my book or not
I mean I'll choose my own strategies so
it's kind of like going around your
question but I would say anything that's
angry or cruel I don't think is
effective because you're dealing with
people and a lot of wounded people I
mean people there are so many people
who've been hurt by abortion women men
abortions in their history and they
don't they still are not even sure how
to wrestle with it they're not healed
from it part of that is they haven't
been able to acknowledge it was a life
it was their child that was killed and
so there's a lot of woundedness so
anything any time that we get on our
high horse if we act with judge
judgmentalism or we're cool and our
cruel or unkind in our approach I think
that can be very harmful and ineffective
so that's probably one of the least
effective things I've seen in the
movement thankfully it's a fringe most
people in the product movement are very
compassionate and there many of them are
there because they actually have
abortion in their families or they were
involved with an abortion themselves so
and then as far as effective is
concerned when people actually learn
about fetal development development of
life in the first trimester I mean from
the early stages and then they actually
get to see that child see that embryo
and then they get to understand what
abortion actually does to that child we
launched a series at live action called
abortion procedures which are medical
animations narrated by a former
abortionist
and he explains he committed at 1,200
abortions himself he explains what
happens during each procedure these are
the most common abortion procedures and
when people actually watch these videos
they're Medical animations so they're
not gory but they're they're correct
they're precise this is what happens
through an animation people are just
floored they they I mean it's amazing we
see people go from I was pro-choice to
I'm guess I'm pro-life because I can't
support that so just something as simple
as showing the child showing the child
and how they're victimized by abortion
and then also storytelling telling
stories women who choose life women who
walk out of that abortion clinic they
have the courage in the last moment
women who had the abortion and then
regret it and they share
stories of abortion survivors they
actually survived the abortion attempt
on their life stories of women who chose
life in really difficult circumstances I
mean these stories are inspiring and
encouraging to people so that's a lot of
the work that we do at live action is to
tell those stories as well as show the
victim and show what abortion does so
one of the issues that constantly comes
up when I talk about abortion that I
assume doesn't come up as much when you
talk about it is I am a man obviously
you're a woman I I feel safe assuming
your gender since you're currently
having a baby uh you know that that
doesn't do a lot today actually that's
that's fair but with that said one of
the one of the chief arguments that's
used by the pro-choice left is the idea
that if you're not a woman you don't get
to speak out on this of course for a
pro-life woman you also don't get to
speak out but why do you think this has
become such a feminist Nostrum that that
the movement in favor of abortion is a
pro women movement as opposed to a
movement that is dedicated to the
destruction of a child like well why is
it becoming us why has it become that
there is such a supposed gender gap in
this area it's crazy I mean you have the
sexual revolution and that happened
mid-century this last century and then
you have the the so-called women's
rights advocates who were doing
important work in the first part of the
20th century I mean they were getting
that making sure that we were treated
equally under the law they were making
sure before that we had the right to
vote but then all of a sudden it got
hijacked by this new sexual libertine
ISM where it's now all about not just my
body my choice that would come later but
this idea that sex has nothing to do
with children it shouldn't have to do
with commitment and then the feminist
movement then became the movement of
basically Playboy types you know saying
we should be free burn your bra you know
sexual promiscuity and then the result
of that too is if we get pregnant we
have the right now we should have the
right to not have to be pregnant and so
we should have the right to end the
pregnancy and the pregnancy choose you
know my body my choice so using these
euphemisms I mean basically the right to
kill so this crazy thing happened where
instead of feminism being what it was
designed to be which is make sure that
we have equal treatment under the laws
with men and we're seen as equal
partners which we are it became this new
thing of a complete
deconstruction of what it really is to
be a woman and an attack on our own
dignity and our children all of a sudden
we became at war with our children so
it's it's absolutely crazy to me that
the so-called women's rights groups
today are the ones that are fighting for
killing our own children which is
antithetical to every protective
instinct and a woman and the most noble
instincts and a woman or a man which is
to care for those that are more
dependent and care for those who are
weaker so it's really horrific what's
what has happened I think deep down it
doesn't resonate with people I mean deep
down I think we're made to love were
made to see life as precious were made
to value children to value sex as
something more than just this thing you
do whenever you want with whoever but
that it's meant for something beautiful
and a lifelong bond so the the anti
messages of the sexual revolution in
today's crazy off the reservation
feminism which isn't the authentic
original feminism I think people are not
really comfortable with it deep down it
doesn't resonate and the more you
educate about what true feminism was
designed to be and the beauty of
motherhood and the dignity of women you
talk about these things I think it
changes change of it for a lot of people
I mean that's the part that is
astonishing to me so as I mentioned
before remember I was pregnant again is
prayer this is baby number three and
she's also as everyone who listens to
the show knows a doctor so she's a
career person and if you asked her what
made her most fulfilled
there is no question which one of those
is more important to her and this is
somebody who spent a decade becoming a
doctors that you can serve other people
and have what I think is a pretty
important career and if you ask her
which one of the being a mother and
carrying a child with you does that make
her feel more fulfilled or going to a
doctor's office and taking care of
patients she will say the former as a
woman now as a human being maybe you
know it maybe being a doctor is is very
fulfilling her but I think that for
pretty much anybody being a parent is
the most fulfilling thing that you're
going to its most difficult this can be
the most fulfilling thing you do in your
life but beyond that the the reduction
of womanhood down to clinical personhood
is really astonishing because as I've
said before it's amazing to me why women
who have a superpower right they have a
super power to create another human
being that comes directly from their
body and nourish that human being and
say that that is the least part of what
I do that part doesn't matter at all the
part that I do that matters is working
2,200 billable hours at a law firm or
going to medical school just like the
dudes do like oh that's fine do it like
enjoy but to to take the part of you
that is the most unique to your sex and
then discard that or treat that as
though that is a downside to who you are
it's it's antithetical to what womanhood
is it's very puzzling right and so much
of today's society is saying a woman's
value is in what she can achieve how she
can succeed how she can compete and what
her the kind of wealth she can generate
or the success that she can achieve or
in her the way she appears
you know how attractive she is when it's
really about our relationships I mean
that is what at the end of at the end of
life and when you're on your deathbed
it's about who did you love you know who
is by your side what did you how did you
serve how did you give with your life
and that's what people we're wired for
as human beings so a lot of the toxic
feminism today is pointing us towards at
basically to choose between say no you
can't have family you can't have kids
you should choose your work first you
should choose your career first you
should choose these other things first
the reality is though if you prioritize
you know put in for me I put God first
husband second my child will be second
third you know will be part of my family
will be second and my my work is still
incredibly important to me I'm still
going to be writing podcasting doing
live-action speaking doing these things
but my family will always come first and
if we can prioritize that way both as
men and women we will be much happier
and our society will be much healthier
and there will be less of an abortion
problem in the first place because
children won't be seen then as this
threat to our futures instead they're
seen as a beautiful part of our futures
but we have to then live a certain way
we can't just treat sex any way we want
I mean this goes back to the way our
culture sees sex I mean that is the root
of the abortion problem is how we see
sex as a culture and how we approach sex
if sex is just something we do whenever
we want for with whomever then yes there
will be unwanted babies so will be
unwanted unexpected pregnancy children
naturally result from sex that's a good
thing it's not a bad thing and sex is
meant to bond two people together and
create a
long bond so if we can restore sex to
its proper context in our society to see
it as a lifelong bond between two people
who choose each other who sacrifice for
each other ie a marriage who commit to
each other and who are open for two
children because that is the natural
outcome a beautiful outcome of sex so I
think that's part of the the solution to
the crazy off the off the road we've
gone with feminism and so many of the
other excesses today I mean at the same
time it feels like that is the area of
pushback where you get it the strongest
from the left meaning on the biology
point it's very difficult for the left
to push back on that because the biology
is what the biology is but when it comes
to the perspective on sex that's where
the left kind of holds up his hand and
they say okay so basically you're saying
either I have to be a pro-life prude or
I have to be a pro-choice person who has
a good time and lives my life and who
are you to tell me they're not even
watching a good time though I mean the
Atlantic just did this whole series of
pieces last year about how people are
not having a good time sexually they're
having less sex their sex is less happy
and they're there's all these studies
being done about how people who are
married and are in lifelong committed
relationships there and they go to a
religious service once a week those
women actually have the happiest are the
happiest and had the most fulfilled sex
lives so there's a lot of research and
the research has been around for decades
actually that shows if you want to be
happy if you want to feel fulfilled
sexually in the rest of your life then
you should marry the love of your life
date them you know take time to get to
know them before having sex with them
commit to them for life and have a
family with them I mean it's it sounds
pretty it's not rocket science but it's
seen as so crazy today
because there are real forces that are
dark forces I think in our in our
society which are ultimately not leading
people to happiness they're leading to
people to a lot of grief well this is
one of the areas where my own
prudishness tends to to bite me simply
because it's not listen I I don't think
it's pretty sure either I have a very
fulfilling wonderful life with my wife
but the fact is that if you promote the
idea of monogamy and that the ideal and
not everyone's gonna meet it but the
ideal is virginity until marriage and if
you don't meet that you know so be it
people sin that's that's what life is
about but you can start over I think
that's the thing you don't have to just
because you you've lived a certain way
in the past you've had let's say 100
sexual partners whatever you don't
to keep doing that you can change your
life I know people who have dramatically
changed their lives so just because you
did something in the past doesn't mean
you have to keep doing it in the future
the part that really puzzles me on this
is again the perspective that feminist
women seem to take on this like I fully
understand why men would like to be
promiscuous I'm a man I get it like this
men and women are built differently
biologically in the mammalian species
men are built to procreate with as many
females of the species as humanly
possible but that is not true with with
human females they are they are built
biologically and by evolutionary biology
to choose the fittest mate in order to
create the the best possible offspring
and so the idea that's been promoted by
feminism that sex is the same for men
and women and if they men and women
experience sex the same and so therefore
if women act like men would like to act
and somehow they're going to be happier
I've seen no evidence that this is borne
out by reality it's basically a lot of
modern feminism is let's make women
should be like the worst possible man
and it's not working for us it's not
working for men either and look yes we
are animals we're we're you know we're
species where the and we're mammals
right but we're also have freewill
we have we can choose we can choose to
love we can choose to sacrifice and even
that man who's having multiple sexual
partners and he's like oh it's so great
at the end of the day he's going home
and if he's lonely as heck because he's
like okay I don't have a intact family I
don't have a woman who loves me who
wants to stand by me because Here I am
you know with all these other women it's
not actually making men happy as what
I'm saying just like it's not making
women happy either so it's not like men
are wired to just go have sex with
anyone because men also have free will
and they also experience the
consequences of bad decisions too and it
hurts them too it's hurting men and
women and I mean you look around our
culture look the anxiety depression
suicide mental health crises is at an
all-time high it spikes every year all
the mental health issues relationships
people are reporting how unhappy they
are how isolated they are it's not like
we're all happy with the way things are
and then you have me too you have the me
too movement where women are saying oh
my gosh this whole objectification sex
have it as you're at your pleasure
however you want it that's not making
people happy either because then the
excess of that is men mistreating women
and then women saying wait a minute hard
stop this is not serving us
and we have the homie to movement so I
think everyone knows deep down this is
not working this whole sexual libertine
ISM is not working and they are deep
down longing for commitment and for
belonging I do wonder whether the
movement toward libertinism despite the
fact that as you say the the polls are
showing deep unhappiness in American
society is really rooted as a backlash
against religion that the the idea of
monogamy and the idea of sexual
commitment because these were so deeply
tied into judeo-christian values
historically that the backlash to that
has led people to embrace positions that
are untenable and to stick to those
positions even if those positions make
people unhappy because better that we
should stick with the point that
judeo-christian religion is wrong and
fundamentally flawed than to acknowledge
that even if I don't believe in the
religious aspects of this maybe they're
right on this particular point yeah I
mean it's interesting I think there's
absolutely spiritual forces at play I
mean speaking as a person of faith
through the first person of faith I
think evil is real I think Satan is real
I think that the evil wants to just
destroy destroy good destroy love
destroy human beings and so a lot of the
ideologies today that are very
destructive in practice whether it's the
pro-abortion ideology or it's this new
form of feminism which is men are you
know women don't our motherhood is not
doesn't matter we can just discard it at
will and we shouldn't value life or
value or femininity I mean these things
I think are extremely there's they're
evil there's evil to them so that
language people I think are very scared
of in our society because we like to
think that evil doesn't exist I mean
it's almost like it's better to pretend
that it doesn't exist it's easier to
live life but until we acknowledge what
is right and what is wrong until we try
to live our lives in a way that sees
people for the dignity that they have
and acknowledge a moral order to the
universe we're gonna continue to fall
over ourselves and hurt each other as
well as ourselves as long as we're on
religion let's talk a little about your
religious background so what is your
religious background sure so I was
raised in an evangelical home Christian
you could say born-again type home and
when I was a teenager I was not really
sure if I identified with that when my
beliefs were I went on this journey to
study world religions and
try to understand okay is it true that
there is a God who is God how should I
live my life what did what is the
meaning of all this so I actually took
some time to study Judaism I studied it
a little bit study different world
religions different worldviews because
again I think everybody has a religion
whether they realize it or not it's the
code by which they live it's the
operating beliefs that inform all their
decisions and I ended up at UCLA
actually interestingly I found myself
just believing okay Christianity I think
is true I think Christ when he said he
was the way the truth in the life he was
correct and he his sacrifice was
necessary because of evil because of our
sin and our woundedness what do we do to
reconcile the fact that God is good and
he made creation for good but there's so
much evil well he he sent His only Son
to die for us so I I believe to believe
that and then my next question was okay
how do I live the Christian life what
does it mean to actually be a Christian
today yes you can say I believe in Jesus
I believe the Bible is an incredibly you
know important source of wisdom and it's
God's Word but how do I actually live a
Christian life and that brought me into
the Catholic Church because after doing
a lot of research and study I saw 2,000
years of church history and apostolic
succession so the practices and the
teachings of Christ when he came which
are recorded in the Bible and then the
traditions of the early church the way
they lived the way they did Eucharist
communion receiving Jesus's body blood
soul and divinity in communion the way
that they did baptism there's an
unbroken line of tradition from the
beginning and unbroken line of the
priesthood from the beginning from
Christ when he established it to today
which has been kept by the Catholic
Church so as a student at UCLA came into
the Catholic Church and it's been an
incredibly incredible gift and blessing
to get to receive Jesus in the Eucharist
and to get to be a part of his church so
to shift rather radically I want to ask
you about the legislative strategy that
you think that people ought to be
pursuing with regard to the pro-life
movement so we've seen a couple of
different strategies that are in pursued
one is the sort of gradual as strategy
which is you gradually push back the the
time that abortion is legal further and
further back so now it's you know
heartbeat or earlier and then you've
seen these sort of go-for-broke let's
just ban this thing outright as you seen
in Georgia
notion that from point of fertilization
that abortion ought to be illegal where
do you stand on that strategic conflict
or do you think that even matters well
first of all the product movement has
been doing the kind of secondary steps
or the intermediate steps for like 40
plus years and it hasn't worked what did
we get we get some of the most extreme
abortion extremism that we've seen in
decades like what just happened in New
York them celebrating nine months
abortion through all nine months and you
still have eight nine states are
pro-abortion through all nine months
allowing legal abortion through all nine
months so that intermediate kind of
going halfway is not been working
strategically and I think it's pretty
clear why I mean in the game of politics
you have the pro-abortion side which
unfortunately is the Democratic Party
right now which is abortion through all
nine months they're not going to
compromise you don't see Democrats
saying oh I'll compromise I'll ban
abortion at this stage that's not
happening and then you have the
Republicans or the at least the non
Democrats over here who are saying
actually we want legal protection but
they're the ones who are starting off
with a compromise so they're starting
off by saying okay let's just ban it at
in the third trimester well they won't
even accept the third trimester ban so
why are you why are you bothering moving
the goalposts so close to the
pro-abortion side my position is twofold
first of all stop the taxpayer funding
of abortion the abortion industry I mean
that's a pretty clear no-brainer we're
still funding Planned Parenthood
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
stop funding any abortion facility or
any any group that's committing
abortions period and then number two
complete legal protection if we're going
to be logically consistent if we're
going to be just to our fellow human
beings we need to ensure complete legal
protection for every single child and we
need to stop playing this game that some
abortions are good some abortions are
okay
women are benefited by abortions this
game that we keep playing as a society
because the reality is abortion is
always wrong it's always the intentional
taking of an innocent human life and
that's never justified so I think the
the right strategy is saying we want
complete legal protection live action
certainly celebrates any time any
pro-life thing happens or is passed but
if we're designing the political
strategy it's complete defunding of the
abortion industry from taxpayers
taxpayers having no part in it and
number two complete legal protection
okay so now I want to ask you some of
the pro-choice arguments that I'm sure
that you get the most so that folks can
understand you know what the
counter-argument is so pro-choice
argument that I've been hearing a lot
lately is you on the pro-life side you
suggest that abortion is the killing of
a human being and yet when it comes to
punishment you're only interested in
punishing abortion doctor so why not
punish mothers why not take the position
that president Trump briefly took which
is that women who abort their children
should should go to jail well where is
the where is the sort of intellectual
consistency there sure well I think it's
a first of all I think it's a no-brainer
to punish the doctors I mean they're the
ones who are actually killing the child
killing that human life and profiting
from it so absolutely criminalizing the
practice the committing of abortions I
think when it comes into the question of
should there be penalties for the mother
again there's a couple things that have
to go into play first of all being
logically consistent if you're going to
kill commit infanticide of your
one-year-old or your six-month-old
should there be penalties than if you're
committing infanticide of your baby just
weeks before he or she is going to be
born and I think that each state and
each community needs to look at okay
what penalties make sense and take into
account all of the mitigating factors
like you do with any case where you're
dealing with the the intentional killing
of a human life may be getting factors
that include pressure and coercion women
that are facing abortion because are
wanting to have an abortion maybe
because they're being pressured or
they're being forced into it or they're
not in their right mind because they're
feeling so much stress or so much
anxiety so I think those factors need to
be considered and then the primary
penalty should be on the abortionist me
so pro-choice question number two and
that is is it
why do you pro lifers conflate all of
the forms of human life why is it
important to protect from point of
fertilization when you have a single
cell embryo as opposed to point of
consciousness or as opposed to point at
which the baby can live viably outside
the womb why are you pretending what why
to use language like you're killing
human babies when what you're actually
killing is a single-celled embryo well
it's we are killing human beings and you
can say okay I'm only going to call a
baby a baby once they're born you can
you can you put the word baby where you
want to put it but the fact is it's a
unique individual human life and if you
start to say like Concha
or your ability to breathe or your
ability to I mean there's some ethicists
like Peter Singer who say actually the
infant is not considered a full human
being because they're not their brain
isn't as developed as they will be in
six months or a year so you can play
that game where basically your abilities
as a human or how developed you are as a
human should equal your your humanity
and your legal protection but I'm not
interested in playing games like that
because I think all human beings should
have human rights regardless of how
developed they are a toddler is far less
developed an adult a newborn is far less
developed than a toddler and an embryo
is far less developed than a newborn but
there's all human beings and so I think
it comes down to do you want to live in
a society where your abilities or your
level of development is is is really
whether or not you get legal protection
you're opening the door to a lot of
human rights abuses if you want to live
in that society
ok the next pro-choice argument that
I've heard a lot I'm sure you've heard
too is the the argument that when a
woman consents to sex and it produces a
child that is different than what a
woman does not consent to sex and that
produces child incest and rape would be
the the example here so in that
particular case then you'd spoken
earlier about how the predictable effect
of sex is that is going to create a baby
that's just one of things that comes
along with sex well if the woman didn't
consent to the sax and now she is forced
to bear the child and carry the child to
term then why should she be forced to
carry the child of her rapist first yeah
and it's a great question because how
horrific is rape and that's one of the
reasons I mean not just violating that
woman's body but that you are going
against her will and her against her
consent and that that could potentially
create a life so it's a complete
violation of everything that is good and
women who are victims of rape or girls
who are victims of rape they deserve our
support our care and our advocacy
if a new human life and that that abuser
needs to be completely punished to the
fullest extent of the law
possible but if a new human life is
created from an act of violence you're
still you're now dealing with an
innocent third party you're dealing with
a new child who didn't get to decide how
she or she was conceived and now it's up
to us in our society to come alongside
and support and help that
because ending that child's life killing
that child would be unjust for that
child that child is that child is
innocent
we don't even give the the penalty of
death the death penalty to rapists in
our country it's against federal law you
can't kill them for for being rapists
why would we give the death penalty to
an innocent child
another pro-choice argument that you
hear frequently is is what I think is
sort of a misdirect which is okay so you
guys you care a lot about babies before
they're born but as soon as the babies
are born you guys don't care at all
you're not talking about resources for
babies after they're born so why are you
so concerned about babies before there
were none other then you just want to
put a burden on a woman yeah I mean we
hear this a lot and it makes me laugh
because basically most of the pro-life
movement is involved with taking care of
babies before and after they were born I
mean you actually get to know the
pro-life movement and there's thousands
of these Pregnancy Resource Center's
that are yes helping women who are
pregnant and then they're helping women
with their infants and their babies and
their parenting classes and relationship
classes and they're trying to create
healthy families so most of the program
movements focus is families and those
bonds of love between parents and
children both when they're in the womb
and they're outside of the women I know
I I speak at a lot of Pregnancy Resource
Center's events my husband and I support
them we volunteered at them over the
years and they're doing that daily quiet
work of caring for mom and baby and
family and baby both when the baby's in
the womb and when the baby's newborn so
there's a lot of work being done in that
space some of the most prolific adopters
and foster families are pro-life
families I know so many of them and it's
something that is just a beautiful part
of the problem that's underreported so I
I have trouble finding that pro-life
person who just cares about the baby
before they're born
the final pro-choice argument that you
hear a lot is aren't you putting an
insuperable burden on women who are poor
particularly women of color the
upper-class white women will always be
able to go get that abortion they'll
always be able to lead the economic life
that they want but poor black women
living in inner cities are not gonna be
able to do that unless they are able to
dispose of an early pregnancy that they
didn't want in the first place I mean I
think that's a big fallacy because an
abortion having a dead baby now in your
history doesn't make you rich doesn't
make you successful it doesn't make you
well-educated if you were the victim of
a horrific rape it doesn't take away the
trauma of that rape so just say that
poor women or
lower-income women or women of a certain
ethnic background are served by abortion
no abortion just ends the life of your
child and then it leaves you in the
exact same situation you were in before
I think the solution is to say okay
let's love them both let's focus on in
our communities through our churches
through our whatever system of
governance we may have locally do our
best to elevate people mothers and their
children care for both of them and
that's a lot of the work that I see a
day in day out in the pro-life movement
so number one I'll ask you relationship
advice even though you don't have a kid
yet and once you have a kid it's
completely their relationship yeah get
ready I'm just I'm just telling you
right now everything that is good in
your life is about to end a lot of new
good things that are going to begin but
very pro-life I love my kids they're
wonderful what I always tell people is
that the is that the boundaries of
happiness and sadness expand based on
where you are in your life so when you
are single basically your happiness you
get up like a seven and your sadness you
get down to like a zero and then you get
married and your happiness goes up to
like a ten and your sadness goes down to
a negative tens if something bad happens
to your spouse then you feel that also
so you doubled your opportunity for risk
and then once you have children all
limits are removed on both ends the
happiest things that will ever happened
you are things that happen with your
kids the worst things that will ever
happen to you are things that happen
with your children so I'm sort of asking
you for relationship advice before
you've experienced a full gamut of
but with that said how long have you
been married at this point a little over
a year we just celebrated a year two
months ago okay and how long were you
dating before that we knew each other
two years
okay yeah okay so so why don't I started
dating advice because there you're an
expert so let's start with a lot in my
20s okay I have lots of I feel like I've
been through a lot of different
iterations of dating culture and what's
going on with dating and I think the key
thing to a couple key principles that I
feel very passionate about when it comes
to dating is first of all what's the
purpose I think a lot of people today
they don't have a clear end in sight
with dating there it's kind of like
cultural thing that they do and then it
becomes maybe hooking up or it just kind
of becomes a almost side part of their
life that's not really focused
are you dating because you actually want
to prepare to be in a family to have a
spouse are you looking for someone that
you would actually want to raise a
family with and be a lifelong partner to
I think
that's a key question what is the
purpose what's the purpose behind your
whole dating approach right and then the
second thing is are you trying to become
the kind of person that you would want
to us lifelong you know are you are you
of the caliber person yourself and the
kind of person that you're looking for
are they the kind of caliber that you
would want to be with lifelong and raise
a family with so it's really a I think
it's really I mean it sounds maybe heavy
but it's like a mature approach to
dating and yeah dating can be fun and
and interesting and all these things but
it really needs to be the clarity needs
that the question needs to be clarified
what is the point and then focus on how
do we become the best person that we can
be so we can be with the best person
that we hope to be with so first of all
totally agree with all of that except
for dating can be fun fact dating is not
fun dating is terrible marriage it can
be terrible yeah I agree marriage is way
more fun than dating I will completely
agree with that and you can keep dating
your spouse and now it's your spouse
that you know inside and out and you
love to the death and by the way my
first year of marriage people said a lot
of things about how hard marriage was
various it is the best it's so much
engine and but here's the thing you got
to put in the work I understand that
like people say well you just haven't
had a hard times yeah well we we worked
when we were dating we tried we really
got to know each other we really learned
about what is our purpose in life how do
we work together how do we communicate
and I know that we're gonna have to keep
working at it the rest of our life but
if you're willing to do the work it is
incredibly beautiful and if you're
careful about who you choose it can be
incredibly beautiful I mean that of
course I totally agree I always urge
people the first thing that you look for
in somebody is values because 50 years
from now you're both gonna be ugly so
just way except we'll both be like at
that point 80 so I mean yes gorgeous
will be a gorgeous 80 year but
realistically speaking it's the values
that are going to last for quite a while
and yes I'm gonna reiterate dating is
awful I remember with that was when I
was dating my wife so we only dated for
three months before we got engaged we we
met on September 5th and we were engaged
on December 22nd and you know the moment
we saw her what was that like I mean I I
knew like right away that she is
somebody who I definitely thought was a
serious option for marriage and within
two
I was like I'm marrying this person and
then she like most women was like I'm
not so sure a couple more weeks yeah I
remember we specifically went on one
date and at the very end of the date I
turned her I said you know I really like
you and she said I like things about you
well and every so often I turned to her
and I'm like yeah what things do you
like about me now now you've entered my
third child how you like that but vet in
any case when we first when we when we
got engaged she she had said she said I
love you December 15th and December 2
and I said to her immediately as soon as
she said I love you the next words out
of my mouth were okay time to get
married and she said why can't we just
enjoy this time together why can't we
just enjoy it any I said because I'm not
enjoying the dating because I'm not
enjoying you anything
I'm gonna lock this down we're gonna get
married and so you were you were
planning to not have sex before marriage
I mean that's well yes this is
definitely a factor I mean there's no
question yeah but but and neither was
she thank God but it's it but yes I mean
she that her determination not to get
married lasted for one week from
December 15th to December so I said yeah
I'm good at what I do what can I say
okay so looking forward to motherhood
what are the things that you are looking
forward to and the things that you are
not looking forward to well I'm looking
forward to actually having this baby
outside of me because I'm nine months
pregnant and so we're almost made it
okay um and I'm looking I mean I mean
it's already been a beautiful experience
to even be pregnant and have this new
little boy in my life and yeah I'm just
looking boy congratulations I know boys
ain't little boys of them they're
they're fantastic and a boy I hear I
hear both so I'm we were gonna be happy
with either yeah except either but I
don't know I mean I think being a mom
I'm excited to have the opportunity to
get to first of all just be with the
baby and have my own baby to hold and
kiss and cuddle because I love babies
whenever I see someone's very my cute
baby is so cute and just the opportunity
to get to form another human being I
mean that's such an incredible
responsibility and privilege and it
makes me want to be a better person I
already wanted to be a better person
when I was trying to find my future
spouse when we got married I'm like I
want to be a good person for you now
it's like okay I want to be the best
person I can be for this child it's just
an incredible motivator and yeah I'm
grateful for that because you can't get
enough motivation mm-hmm try to be your
best how's your husband doing with with
everything he's thrilled he's super
thrilled and I'm more grateful every day
that I married him because I'm like I
got such an excellent man who's very
focused on
want to be a good father a good husband
I want to fight for my family and again
it goes back to like the dating stuff
really being intentional about dating I
mean there are good people out there I
know it can seem like a wasteland
there's probably people listening or
like I hate the dating market and yes
there's a lot of crazy bad stuff out
there I had my share of bad dates but
there are good people out there and the
more you try to be that good person to
to try to be your best you will attract
people who share those values and who
are those good people too so he's he's
very excited than we were yeah we're
excited to have one and then hopefully
have several more yeah you have eight
kids in your family I'm one of eight and
he's one of eight so we've got a lot of
siblings 14 siblings between the two of
us so how many are you looking to have
well I mean I'm 31
so we'll see I mean we were estimator
like maybe we can go for eight probably
we'll probably end up with four or five
I mean God willing obviously but we I
would love to have a lot of kids it will
be a privilege
one of the things that's fun about
live-action is that apparently every
single person who works there is is a
pregnant basically mother yeah I mean
we're like basically one-third of the
staff is pregnant themselves right now
and then we've got several other staff
who are expecting fathers so yeah I mean
it's it's very pro-life but what I love
about that is here we are we're trying
to change the world we're trying to
educate millions of people and we're
very serious about our work
professionally but at the same time we
all know family comes first and we want
to be mothers first wives husbands
fathers first and then our work we're
gonna fight and do our best job when our
work and I love that that mentality
because it says yes our creative
contributions to the world matter you
know we can we can be successful you
know we can work hard but that family
comes first so that means making time
for the family and I'm excited to
navigate that I mean sure it will be
difficult I know it's not easy but I
love an easy life you know why not live
a meaningful life so getting back to
live action for just one second so what
do you think is the trajectory for live
action so when I first met you it was
just in its nascent stage now it's
become a fairly large organization so
what do you think is the trajectory over
the next few years sure so the
trajectory of live action is to continue
to lead and increasing the global
movement to get people of every
background every back every country to
be pro-life
to make live that pro-life ethic in
their lives personally and as well as
politically to take it to the if they
can vote take it to the voting booth
that they can change public policy make
their countries pro-life too so the way
we do that is through mostly digital
outreach and then activism and we are
just getting started
in many ways because yeah we have four
million people following us online but
we need 40 million people on the United
States is a big country and then there's
beyond the United States so we've got
tremendous work cut out for us we want
to completely change culture on abortion
the way people see children the way
people see abortion and then of course
as well impact public policy alongside
that I feel very strongly that a lot of
work needs to be done been on educating
about these other things some of the
stuff we've been talking about sex
relationships marriage family faith with
what what our beliefs are as human
beings what our purpose is because the
problem of abortion is the consequence
of a lot of other things that have gone
wrong
we don't have almost a million abortions
in this country because of some random
happenstance it's because a lot of other
things have broken down in our
relationships with each other and our
families and the way we see even
ourselves in our own value and so I'm
very passionate about alongside live
action doing creative projects whether
it's writing books or doing podcasts or
things like that to educate about
relationships and about what life is all
about and how to be healthier happier
people because those things if we can
get people to see themselves as having
value live strong loving lifelong bonds
in marriages see children as gifts and
not threats see their own god-given
purpose and identity I think that is the
best antidote to abortion so in one
second I want to ask you the final
question which is going to be to tell us
the story that is most memorable to you
about convincing somebody to be pro-life
but if you want to hear Lila Rosen's
answer you have to be a daily water
subscriber subscribe head on over to
daily we're calm click the subscribe
button and you can hear the end of our
conversation over there well thank you
so much for coming by really appreciate
the work that you're doing keep at it
thank you much
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy boring associate producer Colton
Haws our guests are booked by Kaitlyn
Maynard post-production is supervised by
Alex Singaram editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jesuit alvera
title graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20